aujourd'hui de quoi sera fait l'année
2020 un regard sur ce qu'il faut savoir
[Musique]
bonjour bonsoir bienvenue à cette
émission spéciale de rdi économie
prospective 2020 au cours de la
prochaine demi heure nous allons jeter
un regard sur ce qu'il faut surveiller
justement dans les prochains mois le
gouvernement minoritaire à ottawa
les changements climatiques l'élection
présidentielle aux états unis la guerre
commerciale avec la chine
les surplus budgétaires à québec les
marchés boursiers aussi et j'en passe
trois invités avec nous le professeur
annie chalus spécialisé dans les
changements climatiques le professeur
richard où elle est spécialisée dans le
commerce international et vincent de
l'est le spécialiste des marchés de
l'économie à vous trois rebonds jour
répond soir bonjour merci d'être avec
nous pour participer à cette émission
qui est une tradition à chaque année où
on essaie de regarder ce qui s'en vient
en 2020 ce qui est important on y voit
tout de suite avec un premier sujet qui
est le gouvernement minoritaire le
mandat numéro 2 de justin trudeau qu'est
ce que vous allez surveiller de près que
ce qu'il faut voir dans cette année là
s'arrête une année très difficile à
vivre à alger pour le gouvernement en
termes de positionnement sur les
questions climatiques parce que les
élections nous ont montré un schisme
important et donc le gouvernement
libéral va devoir négocier à la fois
avec le npd le bloc québécois et le
parti vert pour des plus d'enjeux
environnementaux plus de place aux
changements climatiques et le parti
conservateur qui coûte que coûte va
essayer de faire un peu dérivé le navire
sur la question du climat
donc ce sera vraiment l'enjeu climatique
d'abord et avant tout qui va retenir
l'attention pour vous chers ouellette en
matière de relations économiques
internationales le canada devra ménager
ses partenaires commerciaux s'assurer
d'avoir de bonnes relations ou au
premier chef avec les états unis la mise
en application de la somme devra se
faire convenablement la ratification de
la cj qui n'est pas terminé on est
toujours à la merci d'un vote négatif
d'un des parlements d'un des états
membres de l'union
alors le guen européenne de l'union
européenne donc le canada devrait
continuer de faire de la diplomatie dans
ce sens là et avec la chine faudra payer
nos relations avec la chine les
relations n'ont pas été très bonne en
2019 on le sait et il
reprendre des décisions en vain c'est la
priorité du gouvernement trudeau que de
rétablir un rapport plus intéressant
avec la chine
c'est important parce que c'est un
marché tellement important il ya des
positions à prendre le canada est un peu
le dernier à prendre position à propos
de huawei la fameuse compagnie qui a
besoin du 5 g pour opérer sur le marché
canadien
la plupart des pays dans le monde ont
pris une position très tranchées très
clair les états unis
ces noms avec un certain nombre d'autres
états dans l'union européenne si oui et
le canada est toujours quelque part
entre les deux donc il y aura des
positions claires à prendre en 2020
vincent delisle qu'est-ce que vous
surveillez en 2020 au canada on est
minoritaire à la baisse qui va aider
notre gouvernement sait si l'économie
canadienne et mondiale
alors faut surveiller si la reprise
économique mondiale se confirme à 2020
c'était plus difficile plus modeste en
2010 note également la pèce bat les
tensions avec avec les prairies en demie
plus tard flüelen pour venir s'occuper
du dossier
ottawa alberta alors si glee vaut mieux
échelle mondiale prix du pétrole de plus
élevé ça pourrait apaiser les tensions
domestiques y donner un peu plus de
marge de manoeuvre est notre
gouvernement minoritaire marge de
manoeuvre en tout cas il y en a sur le
plan budgétaire à québec voici françois
legault
je vais être très clair que les
syndicats je vais être très clair avec
les municipalités il n'y a pas
actuellement de marge de manoeuvre
une fois qu'on respecte nos engagements
on n'a pas de marge de manoeuvre dit le
premier ministre legault en même temps
les surplus on était quand même
spectaculaire au delà de 8 milliards
presque 8 milliards 500 millions lors de
l'exercice précédent
avant le versements au fonds des
générations qu'est-ce qu'on fait des
surplus plusieurs choses qui peuvent
être faits dans l'est sur le plan des
surplus budgétaires mais ce qu'il faut
se rappeler aussi ce qui va énormément
de choix que le gouvernement du québec
souhaite poser on peut penser par
exemple à la question de trois amis qui
si ce projet va de l'avant vont
nécessiter énormément de fonds alors que
si on réfléchit dans une logique de
changement climatique mais le
gouvernement un logo va devoir se
positionner durablement et peut-être
réfléchir la manière dont ces surplus là
pour être plus efficacement répartis en
termes de dette carbone d'adaptation
changement climatique donc ces zones là
devraient pas être des hommes qu'ils
soient aussi prioriser si on souhaite
éviter qu'une dette future aux
générations qui soit faite sur cette
question si nous avions une chance bien
que les surplus ne sont pas tous de
façon structurelle vont pas
nécessairement se reporter d'une année à
l'autre mais il ya une chose ici
d'investir davantage
tout à fait et dans les questions dans
les questions de transport notamment de
transports collectifs d'électrification
des transports est aussi on en parle peu
mais sur les questions d'adaptation au
changement climatique les inondations tu
as eue en 2019 nous ont vraiment montré
que le gouvernement doit se positionner
et être encore plus à l'avant garde sur
ces questions-là d'adaptation changement
climatique sans quoi les coûts vont
juste aller en grimpant de façon
exponentielle dans les prochaines
versions richer le tube et ça
t'intéresse analystes depuis plusieurs
années les surplus au québec c'est
quelque chose de différent par rapport à
ce qu'on est habitué dans les années
passées les les marchés financiers entre
les gens qui prêtent aux au québec les
marchés et sa lettre ici énormément
alors ce qui a été fait dans les
dernières années on s'assure d'assainir
le bilan ont réinvesti à gauche et à
droite on se garde le coup s'est investi
dans le fonds des générations tout ça
fonctionne
le québec emprunte à un taux d'intérêt
qui est plus bas que l'ontario
actuellement on pensait pas cela alors
faut également pour également réalisé
que ces surplus là on les doit un
contexte macroéconomique qui étaient
excessivement favorable au québec
tant mieux ça risque de se poursuivre il
faut pas oublier de garder une marge de
bernay
pour un prodige on y voit un peu plus un
peu moins essayer absolument bien sûr
chawal est l'important je pense c'est
d'investir pour l'avenir alors je
partage tout à fait les recommandations
ou les visions le con mais de mes deux
collègues j'ajouterai que on a un
gouvernement qui est très économique le
gouvernement legault c'est une des
missions qu'il s'est donnée une des
choses qu'il a déjà entreprises et qu'il
devra bien faire atterrir dans l'année
20 20 c'est la réforme d'investissement
québec où on veut prendre un virage
numérique un virage vert
on veut augmenter la productivité des
entreprises québécoises augmenter les
exportations augmenter les
investissements étrangers ici on sait
que récemment le premier ministre
legault était en californie pour essayer
de d'amener plus de sous au québec c'est
ce virage là qui devrait être fait pour
bien préparer l'avenir économique du
québec et donc mettre en application
également à notre tour tous les accords
commerciaux consignes oui absolument
parce que ces accords sont signés mais
leur mise en oeuvre est pas toujours
parfaitement bien fait et le
gouvernement legault encore un petit
cela avec le gouvernement fédéral
on sait que dans le discours du trône
qu'on a entendu début décembre la part
du gouvernement du canada on a promis
une compensation aux agriculteurs
québécois qui sont dans le secteur
laitier
mais il faudra voir la couleur de cet
argent là pendant l'année qui vient
troisième sujet les états unis
l'élection en novembre je pense que si
un événement en 2007 que la planète
terre vous suivent
c'est la réélection ou la non réélection
du président
c'est ce qu'on va surveiller de près
vincent delisle peut-être d'abord là
dessus qu'est ce que vous surveillez de
près par rapport à ce que l'argent de
politique des républicains pour 2020
c'est d'abord d'être élu c'est évident
mais avec une économie qui s'améliore
ce qu'on veut ce que monsieur comme un
nom aussi lorsqu'il rentre au pouvoir
les trois ans on réduit les impôts on
veut on veut croître beaucoup plus fort
que sous l'ère d'obama le chiffre de 3%
de croissance du pib c'est le niveau 2
la vitesse de croisière que présidente
rome veut atteindre et dans lé dernier
trimestre de 2010 9,1 sur et de
croisière l'aube et si on est davantage
à 1.8 1.9 actuellement ce qui est
correct mais l'une des raisons pour
laquelle les peuls américaine a ralenti
en deuxième moitié 2010 9
c'est que les effets de phase de la
guerre commerciale un secteur
manufacturier secteur agricole commence
à avoir des effets dévastateurs alors ça
veut probablement dire une acquis à lui
mis au niveau des tensions commerciales
à l'échelle mondiale monsieur jeu trop
peut-être continuer à japy mordre un
petit peu moins mais c'est sûr qu'il
république et monflanquin demi
s'accélère pour détourner l'attention
des procédures de destitution pour
détourner l'attention à l'égard des
dératés de politique internationale
américaine donc ça va être très centré
sur l'économie
baisser les impôts c'est effet yoyo rien
il ya un besoin criant d'investissements
d'infrastructures aux états unis lui
indiquant que ce problème de délai
réaliste on arrive dans un aéroport
ça fait pitié et ça c'est une mesure qui
pourrait te qui pourrait être promise
pour faire repartir la machine se met du
côté de nos voisins le chat roulette ce
que je vais surveiller mois dans cette
élection là c'est la question de savoir
qui aura le plus d'impact sur le
discours des républicains est ce que ce
seront les protectionnistes continuerons
de dire nous avons intérêt à protéger
notre marché américain the best puis on
n'a pas avantage à faire trop de
commerces avec trop de nation ou est ce
que ce sera plutôt une certaine partie
de la communauté d'affaires il ya un
autre discours dont qui dit apaisant les
tensions commerciales
on aura pas de relance si on est en
guerre avec tout le monde et il faut
s'assurer que les choses vont bien à
l'organisation mondiale du commerce avec
la chine avec nos partenaires donc
lequel de ces deux courants l'emportera
et influences rock discours des
candidats à la présidence michel ou
toujours sur les questions
d'environnement fait la position de
trump a toujours été clair en du
président sera notamment sur la
fermeture des centrales au charbon sur
le faible investissement dans les
énergies renouvelables le retrait du des
états unis aussi à l'accord de paris
donc tous se montrent que la position
des états unis allaient très clair
et pour les démocrates avec comment se
positionne face à toutes ces mesures là
qui ont été de détourner de briser un
peu tout le régime qui avait été mise en
place sous la présidence d'obama
donc ça va être de voir dans quelle
mesure il est incapable de vendre cette
notion-là de grignoter ou par exemple
qui étaient mises de l'avant par
certains élus démocrates
donc comment ils vont réussir à faire en
sorte qu'un nombre suffisant de citoyens
soient derrière eux sur cet enjeu là
c'est pas simple le président trump en
tout cas a mis au coeur de sa politique
des tarifs douaniers sur à peu près tout
ce qui bouge est de plus en plus lorsque
tu arrives tombe y en a un nouveau qui
se joue surtout avec la chine
les tarifs douaniers sont là pour mettre
fin aux abus dit le président des états
unis
est-ce qu'il faut s'attendre à ce que
ces tarifs douaniers demeure en place à
ce que ces tensions commerciales
demeurent élevés je pense que les
tensions les tensions vont demeurer
élevé mais ce qu on a surtout vu en 2018
2019 c'est une phase d escalade alors on
ne participe le point de départ de mes
18 ans et il y en a pas de tarif états
unis ont ajouté quelques 500 milliards
de tarifs sur les exportations chinoises
et vers la fin 2009 on a senti que les
deux parties se parlent est davantage
donc fin de l'escale ce serait déjà une
bonne nouvelle
pourquoi fin de l'escaladé en 2020 parce
que
les deux ont besoin d'un des deux ont
besoin de s'entendre au début la guerre
commercialisé mais les américains que
l'américaine rouler très très fort et
l'économie chinoise avait comme un genou
à terre
deuxième moitié 2010 9 si on regarde
dans le midwest américain tous les états
monsieur jean bruce farr réel et tous
les états qui sont plus liés au commerce
à l'agriculture souffre beaucoup
aux états unis ça va encore bien mais
une récession industrielle une récession
un secteur manufacturier donc les forces
en présences etats unis chine ont besoin
que l' escalade arrête ont besoin d'une
accalmie et on le vue vers la fin 2019
on s'est réveillé une semaine et
monsieur le shabbat à kiel argentine
attaqué le brésil donc est ce que il est
en train de faire un virage pour
continuer de se battre contre des proies
qui sont un peu plus facile
un mot de thurso aux lettres on a
affaire à une guerre qui est très
difficile à prévoir en selon l'heure et
le jour où on surveille les informations
le président antoine soufflent le chaud
ou le froid
donc il est difficile de voir comment
cette cette guerre là va prendre feu ou
s'éteindre pendant l'année 20 20 une
chose est sûre c'est que les deux ont
intérêt à ce qu'on règle les choses on a
affaire à une chine ne l'oublions pas
qui arrive un peu à la fin de sa
capacité de financer d'énormes
infrastructures la fameuse route de la
soie qui l'ont mise en place on sait que
la chaîne a de plus en plus de
difficultés à financer et aux états unis
la guerre commerciale a bien montré
qu'elle ne livrait pas si fruits ça
ramène pas de l'emploi sur le marché
américain
alors tout le monde a avantage à ce que
ça se règle ce sera à voir lequel des
deux présidents vont baisser le ton le
premier avant d'aller à la pause les
marchés boursiers vincent delisle en
2020 dans votre boule de cristal après
une paupière année 2010 9 quand même je
dirais plus que pas peur non pas on
parle de rendement qui ont été déjà de
20% dans la plupart des régions très
très surprenant ce qui est à 6 qui est
assez inusité aussi parce que si on
regarde l'année économique en 2009
c'était beaucoup plus modeste mais les
marchés ont fait de plus 20 alors qu'en
2018 l'économie allait bien
les marchés avaient été légèrement
négatif pour toujours dire cinquante ans
les marchés boursiers tente d'escompté
ce qui va arriver
alors cet anr 2019 ça a bien été parce
qu'on eut des taux d'intérêt qui ont
baissé on a senti que les banques
centrales sont revenus pour faire
partir la machine aider les économies
qui ralentissait nous verrons comment
savoir c'est que le ralentissement en
asie se stabilise à la faut surveiller
ce qui se passe en asie tout cas de la
chine en corée les exportations c'est là
que la planète économique reprend son
auto tunis et de sousse surveiller ce
qui va arriver aux taux d'intérêt ils
ont baissé en 2019
s'il remonte légèrement on risque d'en
laisser un peu peur pour des gains
boursiers
vincent delisle richard ouellet un
échelle ou merci beaucoup mais restait
la deuxième partie dans un instant
édition spéciale prospective 2020
[Musique]